امريكا تفتح ملف اصل كورونا من جديد وتجدد
الاتهامات للصين ومختبروها وتسمم ام تسميم
حوادث في مدارس ايرانيه بتفجر جدل واسع
واسعد المجرد يستانف على حكم سجنه اهلا
بكم
ضمن احدث تطورات كارثه تسمم الطالبات في
ايران تعرضت صباح اليوم عدد من طالبات
الثانويه العامه والابتدائيه للتسمم بغاز
سام تم القائه على عدد من المدارس في
طهران وتم تداول معلومات انه الطالبات
استنشق الغاز ونقلوا للمستشفى وللي
بيسالوا ليه بقول احدث تطورات كانت التسمم
فلانه مدارس كثيره للطالبات في ايران من
يومين وهي بتعاني حالات تسمم مجهوله
المصدر ومو بس هذه اليومين حتى من اشهر
بدات لكن الساعات الماضيه زياده مو عاديه
[موسيقى]
فقدان وعي جزئي وهلوسه ورجع طلع مسؤول
امني قال والله جالسين نحقق في اللي بيصير
وراح نحاسب اللي عمل كده بس يعني لليوم لا
في خبر ولا حس ولا حتى اعتقلوا شخص واحد
على الاقل يعني يكونوا كذا مثلا اشتبهوا
فيه واحد من النواب وهذا متبني وجهه نظر
السلطات طلع وفسر الحوادث وهذا كان تفسيره
عملي
مساله
بعد شويه
وعلى فكره هجمات التسمم هذه اللي بتصيب
الطالبات في المدارس مو مدرسه ولا اثنين
لا صار عددها 30 مدرسه بمناطق متعدده ومو
طالع بيد اهالي الطالبات الا انه يحتجوا
على النظام في بلادهم اللي مو قادر يعمل
شيء ولا يحل مشاكلهم ولا حتى يحاسب
المتورطين وبس جالس يزيد من صديق الخناق
عليهم ما عدا غير انه كثار من الاهالي
شايفين انه النظام اصلا هو ورا اللي جالس
بيصير وامام المدارس وفي الشوارع اليد
اصوات الموت للنظام القاتل للاطفال
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اخر المستجدات في المسلسل هي تصريحات
لوزير الداخليه اللي قال انه حتى الان لم
يصلنا تقرير عن ماده سامه محدده وان الامن
والاستخبارات بحقه بالموضوع واتهم وسائل
الاعلام الاجنبيه انها ما بتنقل الاخبار
الصحيحه وجلسه بتتلاعب بمشاعر العائلات
ايش فعليا ممكن يفسر الحوادث اللي جالسه
تصير هي حوادث تسمم وصارت صدفه ولا حوادث
التسمين ومين وراها وايش المصلحه احنا
سالنا زميلنا الصحفي المختص في الشؤون
الايرانيه مسعود الفك وهذا كان رده
الف طالب وفي 15 نحو 15 مدينه
تعرضنا للتسمم وهذا التسمم يبدو بانه تسمم
متعمد
في طهران في قوم في في بروجيرد في
اردبيل في هذه المدن هناك تقارير عده حول
التسمم والامر ادى حتى الى احتجاجات في
داخل ايران من قبل اولياء وذوي الطالبات
فرضيات مختلفه حول حول هذه هذه القضيه
احدى الفرضيات تقول هناك قد تكون جهه داخل
السلطه تحمل العقليه الطالبانيه
تريد منع الطالبات من الاستمرار بالدراسه
ونظريه اخرى تقول بان لا هذا هو انتقام
الطالبات
خاصه في الثانويه ودورهم في الاحتجاجات
التي شهدتها ايران وفرضيه اخرى تقول
الحكومه هي التي تقف وراء هذه
الهجمات
بتعريق الطالبات الى التسمم حتى
تحرف انتباه المجتمع الى مساله الاحتجاج
ومن خلال وذلك من خلال خلق
حادث هامشي وجانبي داخل المجتمع الايراني
[موسيقى]
من سنوات من اول ما طلع فيروس كورونا
وانتشر وخرب الدنيا والدراسات والابحاث
اللي بتبحث عن سبب واصل الفيروس ما توقفت
وشفنا كيف انه الاتهامات كانت اغلبها
بالطال الصين وحتى سموه الفيروس الصيني في
فتره من الفترات والغرب وحتى العالم كان
في معسكر كامل بيحمل الصين المسؤوليه وناس
بتقول سلاح بيولوجي وقاصدين وانو لا ناس
بيقولوا لا تسرب من مختبر بالخطا الصين
طبعا من اول يوم بتنكر جمله وتفصيلا
الموضوع بس الجديد اليوم انه مدير مكتبه
تحقيقات الفيدرالي في امريكا يعني الاف بي
اي كريست طلع في مقابله على قناه فوكس
نيوز ورمى تصريح قال انه السبب في كورونا
هو تسريب صار في احد مختبرات بوهان وكان
السبب في تفشي وباء كورونا
بالتصريح انه مختبر وهون اصل الفيروس بل
اتهم الحكومه الصينيه ببذل قصارى جهده
لمحاوله افشال جهود الولايات المتحده
وغيرها لمعرفه المزيد عن اصل الوباء
والتشويش عليها تصريحات الاف بي اي هذه
جات من بعد تقرير استخبارات سري لوزاره
الطاقه الامريكيه قدمت للبيت الابيض
والكونغرس بيقول انه اصل الوباء نتج عن
تسريب غير مقصود من مختبر صيني وهذا
التقرير اعتبره تحول كبير في موقف وزاره
الطاقه اللي كانت متردده سابقا بخصوص كيف
انتشر الوباء اما مجلس الامن القومي
التابع للبيت الابيض من التصعيد شويه وقال
المتحدث باسمه جونكر بانه الحكومه
الامريكيه ما وصلت بعد النتيجه قاطعه
والتوافق في الاراء بشان منشا وباء كورونا
بعد كل هذه الاتهامات الجديده الصين ما
سكتت كالعاده فورا جاء الرد على لسان
المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الصينيه اللي دعت
امريكا الى التوقف عن تسييس موضوع كورونا
مخيف
يعني كل ما سبق بيخلينا نتساءل ايش اللي
خلا امريكا في هذا التوقيت تصعد موقفها
وترجع تنشر تقارير انه مختبر صيني هو اساس
كورونا الان هل فعلا دراساتهم خلصت الان
ولا هي جزء من التصعيد اللي شغال مع الصين
واللي شايفينه في قصه المناطيل ومن بعدها
تيك توك واليوم كورونا ينضم الينا دكتور
محمد فايز فرحات مدير مركز الاهرام
للدراسات السياسيه
والاستراتيجيه اهلا فيك معنا دكتور محمد
هل بتعتقد انه هذه التقارير الان وتوقيتها
الحالي اسباب سياسيه
هو بالتاكيد اسبابه سياسيه يعني مساله
تسييس الجائحه سواء فيما يتعلق
بمنشا واساس يعني ظهور فيروس كورونا او
فيما يتعلق بمدى تعاون الصين مع المؤسسات
الدوليه ومع المجتمع الدولي ومدى يعني
وشفافيه وشفافيه التي اتبعتها الصين فيما
يتعلق بهذه الجائحه ومنشا الفيروس هي
موضوع خلاف منذ بدايه الجائحه في نهايه
عام 2019 الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اخذت
هذا المنحه منذ البدايه الان عوده هذا
التسيس او عوده
الجدال حول منشا الفيروس الان اعتقد انه
جزء من مسار العلاقات الامريكيه الصينيه
بشكل عام ليست هذه القضيه فقط موضوع
الخلاف لكن هناك قضايا عديده يجري تاسيسها
بما فيها يعني تطبيقات
يعني التواصل الاجتماعي وهي بطبيعتها يعني
بعيدا نسبيا عن مساله العمل السياسي
وهذا كان موضوعنا امس تحدثنا عن قرارات
الولايات المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي وكندا
انه من حظر تيك توك على تليفونات الموظفين
الحكوميين خصوصا يعني لانه بيعتقدوا انه
هو اداه تجسس صينيه طيب بس هذا كل هذه
الازمات انه قصه المناطيط قصه تيك توك قصه
انه
اللي بنتحدث عنها الان كورونا والتسريب
ليش هذه الملفات كلها الان ايش المشكله
الاساسيه ايش اللي بينضغط عليه
يعني المشكله الاساسيه هي الادراك
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان الصين
اصبحت تمثل خطر بالفعل ومصدر تهديد لوضع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه على قمه
النظام العالمي هناك عمليات تجري او سياسه
امريكيه مستقره بالتعاون مع حلفاء في
مختلف الاقاليم لاحتواء الصين ليس فقط في
الاقليم المباشر للصين لكن حتى خارج
الاقاليم المباشره للصين وصل الامر الى
تدشين تنافس بين الجانبين في افريقيا في
اقاليم اخرى مختلفه وبالتالي في هذه
المرحله جميع الاطراف تلجا الى توظيف كل
ما تمتلكه من اوراق الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تمتلك اوراق عده ليس فقط الصراع
في مجال التكنولوجيا
والجيل الخامس لكن تسييس امور كثيره منها
جائحه كورونا منها التطبيقات التواصل
الاجتماعي وغيرها كل ال ال الاطراف تعمد
الى تاسيس عدد كبير من القضايا حتى او
بصرف النظر طبيعه هذه القضايا وعلاقتها
بالفعل او ما اذا كانت الها ابعاد سياسيه
او امنيه الملفت للنظر ايضا ان تصريح
الصادر فيما يتعلق بمنشا فيروس كورونا
الان يصدر من عن الاف بي اي كان من
الطبيعي او اذا افترضنا ان هذه القضيه
قضيه تقنيه او فنيه صحيه كان من المفترض
ان تصدر هذه التصريحات عن مؤسسات صحيه
امريكيه او عن مؤسسات صحيه دوليه لكن ان
تصدر عن مؤسسه امنيه داخل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هذا يؤكد المنحه
الامريكي الى تاسيس هذه القضيه رغم انها
ليست قضيه سياسيه بالاساس ايوه يعني حتى
الاف بي اي مو اس اي اللي هي حتى بالتعامل
مع الخارج طيب لما بنتحدث ان كل الاطراف
بتسيس في هذا الموضوع حاليا طيب احنا
فهمنا الان او شايفين نماذج عن تسييس
امريكا للقضايا مع الصين الصين ايش بتسوي
الصين تمتلك اوراق يعني مختلفه لكن في
رايي ان هناك مشكله فيما يتعلق بالاوراق
الصينيه انها اوراق اقتصاديه بالاساس
اقتصاديه ذات طبيعه تكنولوجيه توظف القضيه
الخاصه بالاستثمارات مبادره الحزام
والطريق وهي يعني جوهرها قضيه اقتصاديه او
اوراق اقتصاديه بعض الاوراق شبه يعني التي
قد تاخذ طابع امني منها الاتجاه الى تاسيس
يعني
قواعد عسكريه في الخارج كما نعلم هناك
قاعده في جيبوتي هناك تقارير تتحدث عن
افتتاح قواعد عسكريه اخرى في بعض البلدان
على المحيط على شواطئ المحيط الاطلنطي لكن
في المجمل في رايي ان الصين يعني ما زالت
تمتلك اوراق اقل من الاوراق الامريكيه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بالاضافه الى
اتجاهها الى توظيف الورقه الاقتصاديه
بالتعاون مع حلفاء مثل اليابان واستراليا
خاصه فيما بتعميق الارتباط ربط البنيه
التحتيه عبر الاقاليم كمشروعات موازيه
للحزام والطريق لكن تمتلك ادوات اخرى منها
شبكه التحالفات الضخمه الموجوده في منطقه
المحيط الهادئ والهندي التحالفات
التقليديه مع حلفاء تاريخيين مثل اليابان
وعلاقات دفاعيه مع تايوان ومع كوريا
الجنوبيه ومع دول في جنوب شرق اسيا مثل
الفلبين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
بالفعل ما زالت تمتلك يعني اوراق عديده
لكن الصين ما زالت الاوراق بالاساس هي
اوراق اقتصاديه واوراق تتعلق بالتجاره
والتكنولوجيا المعلومات بالاضافه الى
محاولات حسيسه لبناء علاقات امنيه كان
هناك محاوله
توقيع معاهده امنيه مع دول الجزر في منطقه
جنوب المحيط الهادي لكنها في حديث عن
تسليح روسيا في المعركه مع اوكرانيا يعني
هذا عامل كثير جدل ايضا
نعم العلاقات الصينيه الروسيه يعني حولها
علاقه يعني علامه استفهام كبيره حول طبيعه
هذه العلاقات هل وصلت الى مستوى التحالف
هل ما زالت محصوره في منطقه بين التنسيق
العسكري او او التنسيق السياسي
والتحالف كامر واقع هناك حاله من الغموض
لان هذا التحالف لم يختبر بشكل كبير الا
فيما يتعلق بالحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه وما
زال الموقف الصيني حتى الان يعني يقتصر
على الدعم السياسي بمعنى ان الموقف الصين
ما زالت طرف التوصيف السلوك الصيني عفوا
السلوك الروسي داخل اوكرانيا على انه غزو
روسي لكن الموقف الصيني مازال يقف عند هذه
المساله ولم يصل الى مستوى ادانه السلوك
الروسي او الدعم العسكري كل هذه تقارير
تتحدث عن احتمالات لدعم صيني عسكري لروسيا
لكن لم يصل الامر الى هذا المستوى بشواهد
مؤكده فالمساله التحالف او العلاقات
الصينيه الروسيه ما زالت يعني حولها
علامات استفهام فيما يتعلق بطبيعه هذه
العلاقات وفي رايي ان هذا راجع الى انه لم
يختبر التحالف او العلاقات الصحيه الروسيه
لم تختار تعتبر بشكل كافي نحن نشكرك على
هذه المداخله كان معنا دكتور محمد فايز
فرحات مدير مركز الاهرام للدراسات
السياسيه والاستراتيجيه شكرا لك
اهلا من جديد ثلاثه مشاهير كبار في العالم
بتحيط حولهم للاسف اخبار كلها بتحوم حول
الاغتصاب والاعتداء الجنسي منا قضيه شاغل
العالم من سنوات واخرى من اسابيع والثالثه
جديده جدا وسمعنا فيها للمره الاولى امس
بنتكلم عن سعد المجرد وداني الفيس اشرف
حكيمي وخليني في هذه الفقره اعطيكم
مستجدات كل قضيه منهم طيب نبدا مع سعد
المجرد الي من ايام حكمت عليه محكمه
الجنازه الفرنسيه بالسجن ست سنوات ومنع من
دخول فرنسا بعدها لخمس سنوات بتهمه اغتصاب
فتاه فرنسيه صعد اللي من اول لحظه بينكر
التهمه تماما اكد امام المحكمه وقبل الحكم
على احترامه للمراه واليوم اكد محاميه
ومصدر قضائي تقديم سعد لمجرد استئناف
رسميا على الحكم للتذكير سعد كان ومن لحظه
صدور الحكم ودع السجن مباشره
لاعب البرازيلي اللي سبق ولعب في انديه
كبيره ابرزها طبعا برشلونه جالس هو كمان
في السجن من عشرين يناير من بعد ما طلعت
فتاوى اتهمت وبغتصابها في حمام ملهى ليلي
في برشلونه ثاني وضعه سيء في القضيه لانه
الان مغير اقواله اربع مرات والمحكمه رفضت
اكثر من مره طلبوا بالافراج عنه بكفاله
وزوجته انفصلت عنه وناديه فسخ التعاقد معه
لكن اليوم وضعه اسوا واسوا من بعد ما طلعت
فتاه بفيديو على تيك توك وقالت انه داني
حاول من 8 سنوات وفي نفس المكان يغتصبها
بنفس الطريقه وقالت ان المقربين منها
عارفين القصه من زمان انه في نفس هذه او
في نفس هذا النايت كلوب وعمرها 18 سنه
دعاها داني لمكان الفي اي بي وعمل فيها
نفس اللي عملوا في الفتاه الثانيه وقالت
انها تشعر بالاشمئزاز انه بعد ثمانيه
سنوات يرجع دانيه يعمل نفس الشيء الفيديو
انتشر وجاب ملايين مشاهدات وبعدها اختفى
من
الى اشرف حكيمي لاعب المنتخب المغربي
ونادي باريس سان جيرمان اللي امس سمعنا
باسمه فجاه في قضيه اغتصاب هو كمان الجديد
اليوم هو تقرير لصحيفه ماركه بيقول انه
حكيمي واثق من براءته وبينفي صحه
الاتهامات تماما والتقرير بيقول انه موضوع
الاتهامات طلع بالتزامن مع حفل ذا بيست
اللي شارك فيها حكيمي وبدا مبتسم وواثق
وطبيعي جدا وكانت فتاه توجهت للشرطه وحكت
كيف تواصلت معه عبر انستجرام في يناير
وكيف 25 فبراير عزمها على بيته قرب باريس
وبعت لها اوبر وراحت اللي عنده واغتصبها
وعرفت تفلت منه وتهرب وقالت للشرطه انه
هذا بس اثبات حاله وانها ما بتقدم شكوى
فيه لكن بسبب جوهره اللعب وخطوره القصه
الادعاء في عام الفرنسي فتح تحقيق في
القضيه طيب مشاهدينا احنا وصلنا لنهايه
حلقه اليوم انا عد والقاكم غدا ان شاء
الله في اجمل حلقات الاسبوع واجمل ايام
الاسبوع الخميس الونيس في امان الله
[موسيقى]